CNN had a very interesting headline
talking about this kind of energy crisis
recently they had a headline that said
quote why Biden can't do much to ease
gas prices and a couple days ago they
had another article that said oil prices
are finally falling thanks to China and
Joe Biden literally contradicting
themselves just pushing for the
narrative they had another piece today
that was talking about the problems with
the inflation narrative and they blamed
everything on it's all Opex problem it's
all opec's fault no it's not well let's
get let's get into the specifics on the
Strategic oil thing we have the story
from timcast.com bind Administration to
use strategic petroleum Reserve to lower
gas prices the White House will release
50 million barrels of crude oil this
this is It's I I don't think that
regular Americans who like lean Democrat
understand signaling and how the actions
of the administration not not the hard
actions but lie like what people feel
and see based on what's Happening we'll
have an impact so I'll give the example
I just gave when Biden says we're
shutting down Keystone well of course
Keystone wasn't transporting oil so oil
supply is unchanged but people are
predicting for the future if we have X
growth we're going to need X percent oil
increase and investing for the future
investing for the future exactly so when
Biden shuts down Keystone and bans
fracking on certain lands all of a
sudden people say whoa we're not going
to have enough Supply in three years we
better buy it now everybody rushes
everybody buys prices Skyrocket then
what does Biden do oh no something I did
is causing a spike in prices let's dip
into the U.S strategic petroleum Reserve
which is for what economic disasters and
War and other crises and start pulling
out 50 million barrels trying to get the
prices down this is another signal it's
going to be a it's an entropic failure
it's a downward spiral that's going to
slowly spin more and more chaos this
move from Biden is going to cause more
people to be like we are in bad shape
prices are probably going to go up
because of the action of doing this the
what you mentioned the 50 million
barrels of crude oil is what two and a
half days Lydia got that right she got
the quiz right so Biden thinks putting
out two and a half days worth of
petroleum is going to help ease prices
remember it Biden also by by nomics is
kind of interesting it's like he he
pushed he's pushing this latest
3.5 trillion dollar bill they want to
pass and he's saying that that that's
going to take inflation down and pay for
itself now in in what world would that
possibly happen to have like the the a
massive dose of Keynesian spending
um which is look we had a we had a two
trillion dollar bill that we were trying
to get past uh before the election uh at
a time when the economy
needed some help but but here's the
difference
our Focus was on bringing our
manufacturing home we were going to
spend most of that money as a way of
promoting buy American higher American
and I think you uh mentioned the
medicines and things like that there's a
whole chapter in the interim time book
about this executive order I wrote on
what's called essential medicines and
medical counter measures and it was a
buyer American order to to basically
bring home all of that stuff we need the
pandemic was a wake-up call to us
majority of our medicines and uh also um
things that you need for medical
procedures are produced in China China
and and some of that stuff is in India
like if you take like like medicines uh
there's there's the fixed dosage form
which is the end product which which you
get but but in between there's the base
chemicals and and then there's the
intermediate and the base stuff is like
really pollution heavy
um if you're not careful about it and
and in since India and China are not
they dominate the market so we're kind
of stuck so when the pandemic hit like
India started it's like 80 countries 80
countries began rationing either
medicines or machines or both
um when that pandemic hit it's like it's
like yeah it's Kumbaya it's all reason
together no no know economic nationalism
is what what happens when when when the
stuff hits the fan the United States
stole a plane correct me from monk from
France that had PPP in it uh do you
remember that that one I don't remember
but I do have a cool one I can tell you
from the book this was like let's call
it the Italian swab job you remember the
movie The Italian Job with Mark Wahlberg
okay so so I'm sitting um I'm sitting in
my office
um uh it's like a Friday at late on a
Friday afternoon just working my butt
off because the pandemic was like going
crazy I get a call from Health and Human
Services and it's like we got a million
swabs stuck in the Italian Alps because
they're getting Northern Italy's just
getting hit with a pandemic it's like
can you help right so it's like this was
the cool part of the job this was really
cool it's like all right so I call yeah
call a Sit room The Situation Room is
like the cool thing about the situation
room is like literally you could track
down anybody on the planet within five
minutes like if you need to right it's
like hey I need Temple get his ass on
the phone you sir yes sir right they'll
find you you might be playing your
guitar or something don't want to talk
to me but they'll find you right so
anyway anyway
so so I I I I get the Pentagon to uh
agree to uh send a plane
from the factory right
um and and so while it's in the air uh I
realize that well we got to get the
swabs to like six cities so I call up
the the CEO of FedEx tracked him down
through the sit room Fred Smith
um and say hey Fred look we got to get
these swabs out can you can you uh get
get us some of your planes he said yeah
I want you to divert the plane to
Memphis we'll have six planes waiting
for you there so so it's like from from
the time I got the call to the time we
actually landed the swabs in the six
different cities like 72 hours it was it
was pretty cool but that's the kind of
stuff stuff we were doing
um in the middle of the pandemic one of
the one of the other stories in the
interim time book is is worth sharing
it's like the homicide detectives in New
York City were being forced to go in and
process uh people who were this awful
the people who who died at covet right
that the homicide because there wasn't
enough front line responders uh to do
that right and so they're freaking out
because they don't have enough uh
equipment so so the the chief of police
emails the White House and I I did
monahaney if I pull it up and he goes
you know help SOS here so I called
um these two two really cool folks uh uh
a general uh Dynamics
um and and another company in um Phoebe
novakovic in particular would say hey
can you get me some Tyvek suits see
these are these are like the the wrote
you know the the kind of Space Age type
suits right and within 15 hours of
getting that email we had 4 000 Tyvek
suits coming from all around the country
uh from these two defense contractors
that's a that's the thing I was so proud
of this country when you saw good
corporations who would rise to the
occasion and then I had to deal with
with bad ones as well like Pfizer or
Honeywell who just were in it for the
money Tim I want to ask you about uh
what Joe Biden was doing a few key
points that I've I've brought up in you
know with your expertise having worked
on this uh worked in the white house and
all this stuff so I see Joe Biden uh
more regulations right we see him say he
wants the Democrats in general they want
to raise wages they want like you know
higher minimum wage and all that stuff
and I'm all for people getting paid I
just don't believe that you can just
tell people to do it it happens because
there's a big machine of Economics but
they want to raise corporate taxes they
want to eliminate tariffs and uh and
raise wages these three things uh
correct me if I'm wrong you end up with
a corporation in the United States who
says okay we're just told by the Biden
Administration and the Democrats they
want our corporate taxes to go up five
percent so now we're going to lose X
dollars per year here in the United
States they also are saying we have to
pay more so now we're going to lose X
percent more in Rising wages but they're
getting rid of the tariffs
hell let's move the factory to China
then we'll pay people dirt you gotta pay
people dirt We're Not Gonna yeah exactly
and so what Biden has done is he's
incentivized these companies to leave
and take American jobs and now the funny
thing is people say what what has Joe
Biden done it's not his fault it's a
pandemic and I'm like if you just watch
what he's doing yeah and then we look at
this thing with the oil it's like when
the ports got backed up he announces
we're gonna keep these ports up and
running 24 7 or whatever you extend the
hours and a lot of people which didn't
address the actual problem that they
couldn't do anything with empty shipping
containers but of course Biden comes out
and says I'm gonna do a thing and then
these people are satisfied by it they're
like oh well you know Biden's doing
stuff and then nothing changes things
continue to get worse at a certain point
Biden's approval rating is in the gutter
I mean by all almost every poll has got
him in the 30s at this point independent
voters approval rate for independent
voters 24 on Civics he's in the gutter
because people are finally waking up and
being like yo I think these Biden admin
people are burning this country to the
ground you know but he's happy every
morning because he looks at the poll
numbers and Kamal is below him that's
right yeah that's right oh
yes yes yes yes to be clear yes
but Tim your point is so so well taken
because look again it's like confusing
structural problems with with with this
Keynesian kind of approach I think it's
like here's the only way wages real
wages go up it's if People's
productivity increases right if People's
productivity increases
their real wages will go up if you
simply increase the minimum wage at a
time where
um inflation is is going faster than any
rise you can do I mean workers aren't
going to be better off but if you also
like raise the corporate tax and you
have less investment as Tim you point
out the jobs are going off to China
State and staying here the productivity
goes down as well so it's like the thing
that but you just don't understand basic
economics
you said more sensible economic
principles in in the last half hour uh
than than any of the Biden officials
have said since they got there I think
no yeah I think they definitely do
because if you look at what's been
happening who's been benefiting from
this U.S billionaires have gotten a 62
raise during the pandemic there's a
large transfer of wealth happening right
now from the very poor to the super rich
and who's benefiting who's calling the
shots well obviously the billionaires
are getting their way Mom and Pop shops
were destroyed during the pandemic while
of course Walmart Costco Amazon all
those other big box stores were allowed
to be open as we were told two weeks to
slow the spread which was ridiculous we
all sacrificed but the other
corporations got to do whatever they
wanted to do thanks for checking out
this segment from the timcast IRL
podcast if you want to watch live you
can check out this channel Monday
through Friday at 8 pm don't forget to
smash that like button subscribe to this
Channel and if you want more unfiltered
and uncensored content with all of these
guests go to timcast.com and become a
member all of these guests you know and
love in exclusive segments on our
website where we are unrestricted in
what we talk about so you'll definitely
not want to miss it thanks for hanging
out we'll see you all next time